qué tal si todos nos salteamos
mutuamente creen que así podemos
identificar al cristiano
realmente espero no oler mal
[Música]
reunimos a siete satanistas soy
satanista soy satanista y satanista soy
satanista soy satanista yo soy satanista
soy satanista uno de ellos es cristiano
si el grupo descubre al mentiroso se
repartirá en el premio
[Música]
pero si el mentiroso sobrevive ganará
todo el premio quien es el impostor el
impostor 6 satanistas versos un
cristiano ronda 1 ronda rápido díganme
cómo se identifican como ateos
agnósticos pues yo soy atea y pertenezco
al templo satánico también pertenezco al
sol y yo también
yo suelo seguir los dogmas de la iglesia
de sant pero me identifico como una
bruja luciferina yo partícula me gusta
mucho tu estilo
todos lo hacen no me regresa al
principio yo
sospeche mucho de liza por esos zapatos
aprendí solo satanismo por un vídeo de
jubilee que vi hace 6 meses
practico el satanismo desde hace un año
pero antes tuve que superar algunos
traumas que me dejó la religión
cristiana a mí me sucedió igual crecí
como cristiana pero cuando llegué a la
universidad
comencé a cuestionar y explorar mi
sexualidad y no quería creer en algo
capaz de condenar me sólo por amar a
alguien me uní a el templo hace poco más
de un año a mí me gusta el halloween y
todo lo aterrador así que el satanismo
llamó mi atención cuando leí los
principios del templo y aprendí sobre él
me sentí bastante cómoda shelby tenía un
lenguaje corporal que denotaba
inseguridad y yo creo que así es como se
sentiría un cristiano en un grupo de
satán y quisiera preguntarles cómo es su
relación con su familia y en especial
con sus padres
mi padre es la única persona que sabe
que yo soy satanista mi madre es muy
religiosa y siempre me habla sobre el
cristianismo
yo no me atrevo a decirle
[Música]
lo que dijo acerca de cómo se convirtió
en satanista me pareció poco confiable
que no soy yo pero
me gustaría decir que me sorprendió pero
no fue así yo creo que solo me eligieron
debido a mi apariencia tengo una
pregunta para coco tengo curiosidad
porque dijiste que practicas el
satanismo a tu manera cierto no sigues
al templo o no sigo sus principios de
estudio de estimación la ley y la
iglesia no me cuesta sentirme atada a
reglas rígidas o que me restringen de
ninguna manera creo que el templo hace
un buen trabajo pero quisiera que
ampliarán su perspectiva porque suelen
enfocarse en la defensa del aborto pero
creo que hay mucho más que tratar como
el ecologismo el racismo pero hay muchas
fricciones que se decían en diferentes
ciertos sospeche de shelby cuando me
hizo esa pregunta de repente me parece
que ella actuó de sama para que toda la
atención se dirigiera hacia mí quiero
proponerles algo que tal si todos nos
salteamos mutuamente creen que así
podemos identificar al cristiano tan
solo por su aroma ojo espera digo me
agrada la idea pero está viendo alfa te
ame aquí voy
realmente espero no oler mal
yo estoy usando perfume así que
i no tengo idea digo
bueno los olores así que no puedo ayudar
y me sucede la liberación canal no
quiere quiera que las más sospechosas
son coco y tú también porque eso yo que
he hecho de ti porque casi no has
hablado claro pero formación en caso de
que tengan dudas el año pasado me hice
viral en tick tock por hablar del
satanismo a creo que no me conozca así
que porque todo lo que has dicho hasta
ahora suena muy vago para mí como si no
supieras lo suficiente del tema voy a
esperar a poder hablar más
[Música]
me resultó un tanto extraño porque pensé
que ese atuendo de látex lo haría oler
un poco más fuerte pero no lo hizo y me
sorprendió
ella fue quien menos intervino en el
grupo como si no quisiera llamar la
atención
[Música]
contamos los votos y hubo un empate
el empate fue entre cara y chelva cada
una tiene 30 segundos para defenderse
primero chelbi yo nunca pertenecía a
ninguna religión
de hecho crecí siendo agnóstica y tuve
que descubrir por mis propios medios en
que quería creer
yo realmente siento que me identifico
mucho con los principios y dogmas del
templo satánico bueno como como dije
antes era cristiana no voy a mentir
aunque al igual que ella también tuve
muchos traumas de pequeña y siento que
estoy llena de rabia me esfuerzo por
seguir los principios del templo porque
creo que la religión organizada es mucho
más peligrosa que que los mismos seres
humanos así que sí
suerte
estoy consciente de que soy alguien muy
callada y por eso casi no hable hoy así
que no me sorprendió por favor levanten
la mano si creen que el impostor sigue
en el grupo y quieren continuar con el
juego
a partir de ahora cada vez que voten por
alguien que no sea el impostor el valor
del premio será menor bien yo sospecho
de ti
porque no parecía tener ningún aroma
hasta me acerqué a tus axilas y todo no
sé lo que signifique pero es lo único
que puedo decir porque no desconfío de
nadie qué les parece si hacemos
preguntas más personales
yo tengo una bien puede que sea un poco
personal pero quería saber cuáles eran
sus fetiches porque creo que soy yo
común y una de los satanistas que entre
los cristianos es sólo mi percepción yo
estoy explorando mis gustos actual me
envía es decir empecé a interesarme en
los fetiches y no quiero exponerme
demasiado pero fui abusado de niño así
que he tenido mucha confusión respecto a
mi sexualidad pero espero que ahora
pueda conectarme con ella de una manera
más sana gracias por compartir lamento
mucho lo que te ocurrió es terrible creo
que los cristianos también pueden ser
fetichistas a veces sumisos ya no dudo
de ella porque sé que se hizo viral y
tampoco sospecho de ti y me casé con un
drag queen solo para que sepan sin
ofender pero te ves muy cristiana aunque
ligero elegirte porque siento que sería
muy obvio pero también parece es alguien
muy honesto aunque esa es la idea no así
que cómo podemos llegar a un consenso no
sospechaba de ti antes pero ahora
empiezo a tener mis dudas porque pienso
que podrías estar fingiendo sáquenme si
quieren pero tendrán menos y mejor
quiero compartir con nadie eso es muy
lucifer intenta no no los voy a negar he
dudado de ti desde el inicio porque a
noemí si tú sientes de contacto me
parecen demasiado
pareciera que son naturales
y parecía estar muy confiada todo el
tiempo siempre sabía qué decir y cómo
responder tal vez la chica solo sabe
investigar muy bien será que ya lo
eliminaron no lo sé creo que no
yo sigo sospechando de ellos para ellos
la pregunta es algo para convencerte
reniega de grisú
[Risas]
no niega lo niega el poder del espíritu
santo yo lo en el espíritu santo no
existe nada tiene poder
no creo en lo sobrenatural no creo en
ningún dios de hecho soy escéptica no
creo en esto pero crees que jesús es
hijo de dios no creo que ahora empiezo a
dudar de ti porque lo que hizo él me
convenció negar a dios sería una
blasfemia para un cristiano y tú
parecías dudar por un momento viste que
pensado es cierto que estar dentro me
puedes engañar una vez pero eso es todo
ella intentó esquivar la pregunta dos
veces pero no pudo hacerlo más lo que
quiero decir es que yo crecí con esa
creencia siempre escuchaba sobre cristo
día tras día como ella así que como dije
antes yo nosotros también fuimos creados
como cristianos pero que sí y lo que
quiero decir es que creo que estoy en un
proceso y siento como si estuviese
descubriendo nuevas facetas de mí me
explico por eso dudé un poco porque
tengo esa creencia muy arraigada desde
pequeña y me trajo algunos recuerdos
pero aún estoy tratando de dejar atrás
mi crianza entienden lo que digo bien
dudo demasiado así que confirme en mis
sospechas
[Música]
adiós adiós días cuando no tenía el
habló sobre cristo y negocio existencia
supe que yo sería la siguiente eliminada
levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue en el grupo y quieren
continuar con el juego
yo no quiero que un cristiano se lleve
los 500 dólares
si las luces se vuelven verdes significa
que sacaron al impostor y ganaron si se
vuelven rojas significa que el impostor
sigue en el juego y perdieron
[Música]
muy bien
que el impuesto revele su identidad en 3
2 y 1 sorpresa
maldición lo sabía todo el tiempo lo
supe
te juzgue por tus zapatos lo siento yo
me identifico como cristiana pero
cuestionó muchas cosas así que animo a
todos a investigar sobre el satanismo
porque es increíble me alegra que digas
eso porque muchas personas pueden pensar
que el templo o el movimiento satánico
va en contra de los valores o ideales de
la gente cristiana y no es así lo
entiendo de los basile sociales en gente
no le hagan caso a toda esta propaganda
falta
todos me cayeron bien la cristiana no me
ofendió como pensé que lo haría así que
fue genial en un momento me preguntaron
si creía que jesús era hijo de dios y
dije que no pero mientras una parte de
mí lo hizo porque quería ganar
la otra sintió que estaba haciendo algo
que iba en contra de sus creencias vino
vestida de esta manera por una razón en
específico fue para demostrar que los
satanistas no respondemos a un
estereotipo y podemos vernos como
queramos hay que aceptar la
contracultura e integrar a los
marginados suscríbete a jubilee para más
vídeos el impostor quieres estar en un
vídeo regístrate en jubilee media
puntocom casting para más noticias
tienda shop punto y media puntocom